[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 81 of
the weekly Google apart from podcast I'm
Frances Campo and i'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm doing very well how are
you doing France asked doing great
it is Monday afternoon here in beautiful
San Francisco
I think it's Tuesday where you are I've
genuinely lost track of what day it is I
am on vacation this is how I vacationed
apparently in Australia currently but I
couldn't give up on the podcast
I'd still be here the hats arena is not
even knowing what they zinavoy even
though your vacations we still having
our podcast and today actually it's
gonna be a very interesting one
we have Frances Perry she's a software
engineer that works with the cloud
dataflow team and she's gonna be here to
explain everything about it we
interviewed her long time ago a TCP next
not this year but the year before her
for a very quick chat and she's back to
explain way more in detail what cloud
dataflow in Apache beam are so very very
excited about that yeah it's a super
super cool interview and then after that
we have a question of the week talking
about how to securely connect to cloud
sequel instances but when you're dealing
with scalable infrastructure and maybe
your IP address right now is not
particularly stable yeah it is cool
because I actually did not know about
this
so probably many of you will not know
about it or maybe just nothing that I
did not know when everybody else knows
which is fine too but that's the best
thing about this podcast we learn stuff
all the time it's fantastic no matter if
you want it or not but before all of
this content we have as always our cool
things of the week and we have one which
you added which is rewriting movie golf
comm what is this I actually don't know
what movie golf comm is I I hadn't heard
of this either I came across this post
it's on medium it is actually a really
cool article by this gentleman Russ
light who has this site movie golf comm
that it's a trivia game that I think his
dad word like eight years ago and he
decided that he was gonna take basically
what he had previously and rebuild it
and sort of react detect it for Google
cloud platform and how to do it
and it's kind of a really nice step
through of all the decisions he made the
trade-offs he made eventually ended up
just running it on a GCE instance with a
couple of docker images running go which
I thought was really cool
I'm actually not shocked that it was
wearing reading go because as soon as
you said the name actually Ross light is
the team lead for go on the cloud team
at Google so it totally makes sense that
he would do something like this it looks
like a super interesting medium blog
post so I will definitely read it and
there's a lot of really cool things like
he talks about not only the
infrastructure but also the code and
even I think he mentioned somewhere G
RPC or was it just me not that was
telling me but yeah basically the the
whole idea is like the six degrees of
Kevin Bacon which lets you find how many
degrees of separation are in between a
person n Kevin Bacon taken into account
every step as someone that has done a
movie with someone else
yeah and that's cool he goes through
he's like okay do I use App Engine do I
use container engine do I use GC
instances why did I choose which one
thing I did so it's a good it's a good
trade-off discussion yep very very cool
we have a second cool thing of the week
and I'm actually very excited about this
one so I'm gonna even though is the
third one on the list I'm going to say
on the second because I'm very excited
about it many of you might have
applications running on App Engine and
many of you might have custom domains
such as you know GCB Potter come for
instance every single time your HTTP
your SSL certificate is too old you need
to change it and to do so you actually
needed to login into the console because
there was no API well that has been
fixed there's now an API and also that
API is also accessible directly from
g-cloud so that's super cool and I'm
looking forward to people hacking
something to make it so let's encrypt
will update the HTTP as the sell
certificates as soon as you need them so
very excited about that super cool I had
been waiting for this for quite a while
so really cool that we have now we have
a link on the show notes to the
announcement but basically that is the
most important thing you need to know
there's an API yay yeah I know franceska
that's gonna make your life a whole lot
easier I know when you've been managing
as
CEL sets on a CB podcast that has been
driving crazy cool so final thing which
has to do with gr pc and the newly hot
sto we have heard all the comments and
emails that people have sent us we are
looking to do a podcast in the near
future on sto don't worry we have heard
you we definitely want to do this but if
you're in the Bay Area or specifically
Sunnyvale and you're interested in
coming down for a community Day there is
going to be one on Monday June the 26th
down in Sunnyvale we'll have links in
the show notes where there will be
developers for G OPC and sto if you want
to go down have a chat with them talk
about what's going on and talk about the
open source and ongoing efforts bring
your laptop and show up and they'll be
cool stuff going on nice that sounds
like a very cool place to learn about
the new technology and make cool friends
- I'm always up for making cool friends
yeah cool so I guess it's time to go
talk to Francis variable data flow yeah
let's do that
I am very happy today to welcome Francis
Perry a tech lead on clubbin flow and
also a PMC at Apache beam hello how are
you doing Francis doing well thanks for
having me and I am very excited to have
you because it is actually not the first
time we have you it's the second one but
that was long time ago yeah that was
over a year ago
yeah TCP next you gave an amazing talk
on data flow and since then many things
have changed so we will be talking about
all the new things about data flow and
Apache beam but before that I think it
does a little bit about yourself and
what you do at Google okay so I'm a tech
lead on the cloud dataflow project where
I focus particularly on the user facing
surface of the project so that's our
client-side SDKs monitoring UI's tooling
documentation basically making sure that
at the cloud dataflow service we give
users a coherent vision for how they're
executing their processing pipelines
cool all right so at a high level what
is data flow what is this thing and what
does it get used for yeah so cloud
dataflow is a fully managed services but
it's fully integrated with Google cloud
platform for executing batch and
streaming data processing pipelines so
you can
think of it sort of as a successor to
systems like MapReduce but it also
brings in a lot of the more recent
streaming technologies so it can do both
sort of your traditional badge ETL style
things as well as real time applications
cool so when I think about MapReduce I
think basically say big data you run a
big job and yet thank you done like you
run it during the night and hopefully
the morning after you have the results
but you saying that data flow also
allows you to do this trimming what kind
of use case have you seen like what why
would I use data flow so I think the
thing that makes data flow really unique
is basically two things so there's first
of all the programming model or the way
you write your programs and then there's
also the service which is fully know
knobs and fully managed so basically it
tries to do as much of the tuning and
things as it can for you on the
programming model side this is really
where we're tying into Apache beam and
so this this programming model that you
use for talking for describing your data
processing is really a new way to think
about how to process data across
distributed systems so if you go back to
2004 right what MapReduce did when we
publish that paper is really gave us a
new set of abstractions for thinking
about what until then had been an
extremely complex problem about how to
process data in parallel across multiple
machines and have fault tolerance and be
able to do it efficiently at scale so we
think of basically the beam model and
the way that you're writing these
programs as doing that next step but now
for unifying both batch processing and
your real-time streaming processing so
what exactly is real-time streaming what
does that mean like for a lot of people
who don't necessarily deal with that so
this would be anything where you're
processing really an infinite amount of
data so if you think about the way data
is generated these days it's really
often an infinite stream so I think one
of my favorite examples to use is a
mobile gaming application so let's say
that we've just launched some new mobile
gaming application and we've got users
all around the world
frantically crushing candy doing
something to earn points for their team
right and these scores are coming back
to our system and we want to go ahead
and analyze you know what's the top
scoring team right now so in a system
like that once the game launches that
data just keeps coming in
right a traditional sort of batch style
processing what you do is chunk your
logs into days so here's my logs from
Monday and now I can analyze them right
maybe so Tuesday at 1:00 a.m. I can
start analyzing Monday's logs because I
have all that data so that's sort of
doing in a badge style system but in the
streaming of a real-time system you want
to be doing things as the data arrives
you want much lower latency you want to
have a leaderboard that you're
displaying of the current top team right
and that becomes so both low latency is
important there and also because of
distributed systems you need the
flexibility to handle data that comes in
out of order because if you think about
how distributed systems work you can't
guarantee that your data will come in
immediately on time right people's
network connections get delayed phones
go offline and so on so you need to be
able to adjust and process these sort of
out of order infinite data sets cool so
we've been mentioning two sides of the
same thing right we've been mentioning
on one side the programming model which
is kinda like MapReduce but but better
it has knee operations and whatever and
then on the other side is the runtime is
that the separation between data flow
and Apache beam what what are the
differences so originally when we
started with data flow when I went into
GA and 2014 they were the same we had
the data flow service and the data flow
SDK which you used a program against the
service but more recently so about last
January why would that be 2016 we
donated those SDKs to the Apache
Software Foundation and helped kickstart
the Apache beam project so now that is
exactly true basically Apache beam is
this way of reasoning about your
programs and Apache beam pipelines can
run in multiple places one of those
places is on the fully managed cloud
dataflow service the other options are
things like on apache spark apache flink
and other common open source runtimes
let's go back to that we said that the
runtime is different like if you're
running MapReduce it's patching while
you're running there flow you get
streaming but what about the programming
model what is the main difference
between those is there also like map
shuffle with use phases or how does that
work so I think there's really there's
really
big difference is there between sort of
a MapReduce API and what beam gives you
the first one is that the the way you
specify your business logic is higher
level when MapReduce came out people
realize they could solve basically any
class of problem in a MapReduce if you
sort of took your algorithm twisted it
enough distorted it enough and shoved it
into that map shuffle reduce structure
so a lot of the newer systems including
SPARC and flank and cloud dataflow and
beam are doing things where they give
you a higher level graph abstraction for
talking about the different
transformations you want to do to your
data and then we ensure that the system
is able to sort of optimize that down
into a lower level thing so if you think
about something like function
composition if you want to take a data
set and you want to go through it you
want to tokenize it to pieces and then
you want to take each word and you want
to lowercase them right when you're
writing that in a MapReduce style system
you would do that in a single map
operation where you take the line of
text you tokenize if you lowercase it
now put those lowercase words what
you're doing there is you're being
forced to hand optimize or fuse two
unrelated pieces of logic into one
method in order to get the efficiency
out of the system because you don't want
to go through large data sets multiple
times on the other hand with these newer
styles of systems we separate that out
and let you as the user write your
business logic and a higher level
abstraction so you can you can think
about the logical phases not as their
most efficient to execute but as they
make the most sense for your algorithm
for expressing what you're trying to do
and then you let the system do those
optimizations to run them efficiently
right and this is basically the same
difference that people have had with
assembly language and then higher-level
languages coming along later you let the
system do the boring nastiness of really
getting every ounce of efficiency out
and you give somebody the right set of
abstractions to talk about what they're
trying to do so it doesn't mean that
what you're doing then you're describing
this graph like this pipeline using the
Apache beam language well let's call it
a language like API or whatever and that
is Apache beam and did you generate that
graph and how you run it is complain
dependent and that's where you could run
it on cloud dataflow or spark or any
other runner is that is that correct
exactly correct
yep that is very cool so I'm actually
curious about one actual thing
well two about finding the right spot
for using these tools quite often when
we talk about like people who have gone
to higher abstractions or other
technologies other than MapReduce for
doing these sort of big data data set
type stuff we talk about bigquery a lot
for obvious reasons so as a general rule
of thumb where do you find that people
are like oh data flow is a better fit
for this whereas bigquery is a better
fit for this where do you draw that line
well I think you know they do absolutely
overlap in in some use cases but I think
if you've ever tried to write some
really complex sequel queries right you
you will hit up against the bounds of
what that abstraction is really suitable
for release for mere mortals so
something like beam does give you sort
of a little bit more flexibility there
but I think there's a lot of interest
for example in the beam community and
writing a sequel DSL that runs on top of
beam so they are quite related there's
been additional functionality added to
bigquery to get you know better join
support and there's been a lot of
improvements over the years that have
brought these two systems closer
together but really I think that there's
less of a cliff when you're running in
data flow like the types of things you
can do are just more flexible you can
integrate with a much more different
data sources sort of the streaming the
real-time capabilities are there so
since you're mentioning data sources I
think that that's a interesting thing
like we talked about pipelines what do
we connect normally is it anything you
want anything we want anything I'm
connecting my suckster database go for
it beam beam is really designed to be
extensible in many different ways
and so one of those is the input format
that you're writing to so beam has an
API called the source API that you can
use to teach beam about a new data
format and the reason you need to sort
of teach it explicitly about the format
is that we want to make it very easy to
run this efficiently in parallel so if
you think about a new data format you
need to be able to answer questions like
how big is that data format how would
you split it into X pieces and then how
would you read a piece right and those
are really what are required for the
different runners behind beam to take
that and parallelize it and then across
multiple workers sort of chunk that data
set up into pieces and hand them out to
different workers one thing beam does
it's more advanced than many of the
older API is out there is add a notion
of what we call dynamic work rebalancing
so as you're teaching beam about a new
input format and you're telling it how
you're reading sort of a chunk of that
format beam also asks you to provide
signals about your progress through that
and then potentially stop early so what
that lets the system do is divide the
input set into ten pieces
farm them out to ten workers realize
that one of the workers is really really
slow and tell that worker actually
you're only 20 percent of your way
through your data can you please stop at
40 percent I'm going to steal that last
60 percent and reassign it to somebody
else who's got idle cycles dynamic work
rebalancing has been a huge thing for
improving straggler shards which is sort
of this really common problem and
distributed into processing where either
because of slow machines or data
characteristics or something you end up
with like a huge number of parallel
machines sitting idle while one machine
chunks away on the remainder of the work
so going to assume there are a bunch of
like connectors for like GCP stuff like
I'm guessing pub/sub things like that
does that mean then you have to like
teach it how to use pub/sub or does that
work out of the box yeah thank you for
clarifying that we have a lot of built
in connectors your standard GCP ones are
there bigquery pub/sub all the various
textual formats which kind of course
come from GCS one of the things that I'm
really excited about kick-starting the
Apache beam ecosystem is really that
open source environment is where the
diversity of connectors is really coming
from so since we sort of kick-started
beam in the last year we probably added
fifteen new connectors there's Cassandra
and Kafka and Kinesis and all sorts of
things coming out of that which i think
is really great for helping people get
their data into the systems that they
need to process it in sounds like
there's a great relationship there
between Apache beam and dataflow so on
the dataflow side I'll ask like what
integrations with other GCP systems you
just talked about like that's our stuff
but is there like I don't know logging
or alerting absolutely what integrations
does it have with GCP specifically on
data flow side so we're trying to
integrate as tightly as we can with so
many of the other systems right because
when you come to GCP as a platform what
you're really looking for is for all
those systems to work beautifully
together what happens when you actually
launch a data flow
is that you write an Apache beam
pipeline and you're running a program
somewhere could be locally on a server
of your own somewhere it's describing
the shape of this data processing dag is
this graph that you want to run so then
you what happens is that that gets
serialized into into JSON and sent to
the data flow service and this is the
description sort of the the outline of
the the processing and some of that
processing will include serialized bits
of user front user code this is the
actual things you want to do for each
element right but from the data flow
systems perspective it basically has a
plan or a map you know a plan of the
different processing it then spins up a
bunch of GCE workers who it will
actually farm all that work out to so
your code is that you've written to
process all your elements is happening
on GCE VMs but those VMs are going to be
fully managed and auto scaled by the
dataflow service so you don't need to
worry too much about how to manage them
but they're there if you need them as
those VMs are processing each of your
elements they're logging into cloud
logging and then we have some really
great integration with cloud logging
that lets you very easily sort of search
your logs right in the data flow UI and
see what different portions of your
pipeline are logging we're adding some
some additional integration with with
different different tools and
stackdriver to get better monitoring of
how your water marks are going what your
errors are all these types of things
we've covered the input we've covered
the wallets running how you can see
what's going on yeah what about the
output do you store it in a file can you
choose or it's more like you were
mentioning that there was like sequel
statements that you can run so basically
just like you can teach the system about
new kinds of input formats and we have a
bunch of common ones built-in same thing
will hold four outputs so you know you
can very easily write to bigquery in GCS
pub/sub you know your standard sinks and
also if you have something else you need
to do you want to call out to a
third-party system or write a custom
file format or something like that you
have the flexibility to teach the system
about additional things there as well
interesting so does that mean that for
instance if I'm doing streaming how
often do I write to the output that's
going to be very application
specific what we liked about beam is
that you write your application logics
or this thing you're doing to your
program once and it's very easy to
customize that same algorithm for
different latency situations so if you
think about writing going back to our
mobile gaming example if you think about
writing a computation that sums the
scores per team you write that
transformation just as if it were taking
a big collection of pea collection of
team and scorer events and basically
summing them up across unique teams then
when you run that you can apply it in
different ways you can window it which
means you want that computation applied
over different slices of event times you
can say take that integer summation and
give me at some per hour or per minute
or per day right and choose sort of the
the scope of that you can also customize
the triggering which is how the
relationship to the processing time
comes into place you can say I want you
to sum it over all time but I want to
know an update of what the current score
is every hour so I want you to sort of
accumulate overall time over the bigger
window but I want smaller updates you
can also say and I want to know if late
data comes in because one of the things
you'll find in a streaming system is
somebody's playing our mobile game on a
transatlantic flight they're in airplane
mode and then they land you know four or
five hours later they have to reconnect
to a network and so sort of you're
getting a score that comes into the
system multiple hours delayed and you
have to figure out how to adjust that
into the computations that you've
already been performing cool so you said
something that took me back to the time
I wrote at cloud dataflow job which is
that peak collection and I'm actually a
go developer and I know that peak
collection is a very very java thing to
say I know that you can run data flow
well you can program me beam pipelines
with Java is there any other languages
and what is the plan in there right so I
think that one of the things we're
really excited about with beam is that
we've designed the system from the
beginning to really focus on
extensibility and portability to the
point where it's designed to support
multiple SDKs as the community is
interested
writing them those SDKs really are just
generating that that graph right which
is itself just a language agnostic plan
or representation of the computation
it's only the little bits of user code
in that plan that are a specific
language so it's actually quite an
extensible format and then the different
runners can take that plan and go ahead
and run it very easily and then they
just need to know how to basically call
back in to the specific language on a
per element basis so what that enables
is the community to really grow by
adding new SDKs and setting them up so
that new SDKs can run across all the
different runners so that's the vision
that it's a fully mix-and-match of
choose an SDK chooser run our life is
good
visions are never there always a journey
so we're beam is that right now is that
we have a Java SDK that ports across I
think four different runners in the
mainline branch and another runner on on
a development branch and then we also
have a Python SDK that's that's fully
merged on the master branch but we don't
yet have the portability story totally
fleshed out for that so the Python SDK
right now can run locally for
development and testing and it can run
on the cloud dataflow service and the
community is actively working towards
getting that running across the other
runners as well so what does a pipeline
look like when you've described it in a
language meaning is there like some JSON
way of communicating that to the runtime
it's like XML or we will have a language
agnostic format that it can use to do
that interchange for the users we won't
have them interact with that directly
taking a conceptual abstraction which is
what the beam model really is right this
idea of P collections and parallel dues
group by keys windowing triggering we
haven't even gone through all these yet
and materializing it in different
languages for specific user communities
is a challenging problem because you
want to make sure that the abstractions
feel native right when in Python do is
the Python Ian's do something like that
you know you don't want it to feel like
it's a Java abstraction forced into a
different format so that takes sort of a
subtle touch to both make make the
abstractions clear as to what they are
and also
native to the different language
communities bro nice awesome
so we talked a bit sort of we talked
about from the technical stuff and like
we've talked about data flow we've
talked about beam I'm curious so beam is
running inside the Apache foundation how
is the like organization structured
there I'm guessing we're still heavily
involved they're like what's that
open-source community look like so so
Google had the bulk of the code for the
original dataflow Java SDK and we had a
couple of other partners we are working
with cloud era and data artisans and
talent who are writing runners and other
sort of things that could integrate with
this SDK and so together the group of us
basically proposed the Apache beam
project to the Apache Software
Foundation and donated the sort of
initial codebase and since then we've
really grown into a full-fledged
community when you're working with the
Apache Software Foundation it's very
much an open community driven by
individuals so it's not specific
corporations doing things but you're
really acting on behalf of the project
so I think one of the things we're the
proudest of sort of is how we were able
to take something that was originally
basically a proprietary single company
thing and start to transition it into an
open ecosystem with a whole bunch of
diverse perspectives new people coming
in being welcomed into the community
that's been that's been quite the
journey for the last year for many of us
um ok and I'll ask you because I'm quite
curious what's the most like interesting
or crazy or imaginative thing that
you've seen somebody do with dataflow
you know I always have trouble answering
this question because it's such a
general framework that you can do
basically anything I think for me the
thing that is the most compelling is
really these sort of mobile gaming
application because what I really like
about that is it brings home pretty
easily I think the complexities of
working in these real-time distributed
systems if you go and look on the cloud
dataflow site we have a mobile gaming
walkthrough which we do there show you
how you build a simple batch pipeline to
do your summations of you know team
scores or something and then you start
adjusting it until by the end you've got
a really complex streaming pipeline
that's working over real-time data
ruling out spam robots what we've built
is something that can really give you a
gentle ramp to learning and adding these
new technologies
and that gives you so much flexibility
for how you as a developer adjust your
programs as things move along right as
your needs change because they will
right people be doing bad for a very
long time people know that they should
probably be doing stream processing but
it's kind of hard it's kind of complex
so what we really want to do is let you
sort of pick and choose and as your
needs change be able to very flexibly
shift your style of processing cool so
we're running out of time a little bit
but has there been anything that we
haven't had a chance to mention or you
want to make sure you plug or make sure
the listeners hear about yeah I think I
you know since I'm on the SDK side of
things I haven't talked too much about
the dataflow service and it's no nobs
approach to things so I think you know
one of the things that people realize is
you know maintaining and tuning your own
cluster can reappear not only is it a
pain to manage those things you also end
up needing to change that tuning as your
data sizes change or you're processing
changes right so one of the things that
that's really exciting about data flow
is that it's fully auto tuning so it
will choose the number of workers that
your your application your your pipeline
needs to run and it can change that over
time right and that's either because
you've got a streaming pipeline and you
had a huge spike in user traffic right
and all of a sudden you're going to need
to drastically scale up right or you're
processing a large number of logs and
you drastically filter down into just a
small data set and then expand that out
again so sort of even though your
pipeline might run for 12 hours there
might be a period there in the middle
which is very little processing to do
you want to be able to take throw a lot
of machines out at the beginning scale
them down while they're idle because
there's no no additional data to process
and then scale them back up is you need
to awesome that sounds that sounds like
a great experience for developers so one
last question for people that want to
learn more about dataflow Apache Beam
what's the link yeah so I would start on
cloud.google.com slash dataflow that's
got all your basics about the cloud
dataflow project for beam you'd go to
beamed out Apache org perfect well thank
you so much for taking the time today to
talk to us and explain a little bit more
about what cloud dataflow and Apache
beam are thank you excellent thanks guys
so think
to Francis for joining us today to tell
us all about dataflow really great
conversation and really interesting
especially because I don't play as much
with the big data space so I really
enjoy hearing about what capabilities we
have in this area for big data and
analytics and especially streaming data
so much thanks to Francis for joining us
today yeah definitely definitely
interesting conversation I learned a lot
and I'm still not sure if I'm gonna be
using now if I use data flow I don't
know if I will write Java or Python or
just wait until there's a go SDK for
that you know you want to write to
heighten you want to write Java I know
you do
yeah we're JavaScript anyway it's time
for our question of the week comes from
one of our listeners
Chirag Nayyar and he is asking about ok
so I'm trying to set up my web
application quit with cloud sequel which
is great idea if you need to run a
sequel database cloud sequel is a great
place to do so he's saying that the app
is running on GC Google compute engine
and he wants to implement autoscaler and
manage instance groups now the problem
is that when you want to set up a
connection with cloud sequel one of the
ways of doing this is to wide-based the
IP of the instance that will connect to
it now if you have a managed instance
group you do not know necessarily how
many instances you're gonna have so how
do you do this
and I came up with a solution and I'm
gonna say it first but then we're going
to talk about the actual good solution
that you you gave and my solution was
well if there's any way you can know
what is the range of IPs that your
instances will have then it should be
quite easy to to simply whitelist the
range of a piece that you may have but
now the problem is that what if that
range is limitless like you don't really
know how many instances you're gonna
have you may have two and maybe twelve
but at some point maybe you'll have in
that 20 and then those eight that you
didn't count on well they will not be
able to connect so that is not really a
very scalable solution so you came out
with a very very good solution so why
don't you go and explain it in person
and come up with this engineers a group
of a came you came out with the name of
the solution I guess
yeah so there's there is this really I
think it's a neat sort of thing called
the cloud sequel proxy it works first
from my sequel and Postgres basically it
is an agent that you can run on your
machine so either in this instance we're
talking about compute engine but you
could run on container engine docker
instances even locally on your client as
well
so it's an agent you install you
provided some credentials so basically
you know service Keys much like you
would do with just about anything else
and you can do that through like local
environments or files also different
stuff I'm pretty sure you also even
words with default credentials so if
you're running on GC it just
automatically works so there's there's
lots of nice ways of doing it and then
so you run this agent locally and its
job is to securely over SSL proxy the
local connection you have for say my
sequel from the local machine or that
agent specifically over to the cloud
sequel instance so this means then if
you're running this proxy and has the
right credentials set up and
everything's great and you're running it
locally you don't need to do IP ranges
you just connect to your cloud sequel
proxy and it handles that whole security
thing for you it's actually pretty
pretty easy to set up it's just a little
agent you can set up and run if you want
to run it there are also a series of
walkthroughs that are available in the
documentation that show you how to do it
from compute engine from container
engine and local client that kind of
stuff too so it's pretty great and most
of all it's also open source you can go
and have a look at how it all works it's
on github and you can check it out -
nice cool so I hope that that answers
the question of track Nayyar he also
mentions hey you does you still have an
episode on cloud sequel which you know
gives us an idea maybe we should do an
episode on classic we'll always love the
suggestion from the community it gives
us ideas for content yeah awesome well
Francis thanks again for joining me for
yet another episode have you been up to
anything interesting I think I saw a new
just for funk episode this came out yes
I finally released it just a days late
because you know Australia and things
but Australia sorry Argentina you're in
Australia I was in Argentina different
country but yeah I came out is about
Sego also how to call see libraries from
go it is pretty cool even though like I
made it but I actually learned a lot by
doing it so if you've ever
wondered how to do it go watch it also
I'm actually getting ready for going to
New York very soon on the 26th at the
same time at that Eastern meetup that we
mentioned the amount of you I will
actually be in New York for cucum well
we will be running go tooling in action
workshop so pretty excited about that
what about you are you ever coming back
to the Bay Area I am coming back my
house is there and so is my dog and I
need to come home to my dog oh good yeah
so it's not about me it's about the
about the dog you're quiet it's like I
am coming back yes so I'll be back in a
little while where am I going to be I
don't know where I'm going to be for the
next little while I'm spending some time
in San Francisco working on some
projects I have a secret project in the
works that I haven't told anyone about
but I expect I'll also have some blog
posts out more about game servers and
kubernetes coming out in the next few
weeks as well and so taking a little
travel respite we'll see what happens
very cool awesome well Francis thanks
again for joining me I know I said that
before but I really appreciate you
taking the time I love doing these
episodes with you so thanks again for
yet another week thank you Mark taking
time out of your I'm sure incredibly
busy crowded vacations but well-deserved
vacation thank you and thank you for
listening see you all next week
you